Ma tu non ti devi preoccupare dei soldi
se te li chiedono poi gli ridiamo digli
di aspettare Vabbè se ti Spezzano poi le
gambe Non ti preoccupare Chiamo il
medico Ciao bambini oggi parleremo di
uno dei giocattoli che più ho voluto
nella mia vita e non mi è mai stato
preso Emilio il famosissimo robot da
compagnia 100% di produzioni italiana e
infatti non si chiama Emilio si chiama
Emilio con la G Sai perché si chiama
Emilio perché miglio è meglio
perché è Emilio Emilio Non è italiano
tra l'altro è meglio è uno dei primi
giocattoli radiocomandati italiani
Infatti tu col telecomando potevi
muoverlo Avanti indietro a destra a
sinistra poteva illuminarsi potevi
addirittura parlare nel Joypad per far
riprodurre la tua voce Va bene Vi faccio
una domanda Qual è il vostro film
preferito Il re leone La Sirenetta
oppure l'indimenticabile capolavoro del
cinema Rocky 4 ve la ricordate la scena
dove c'è il compleanno dello zio Poli a
cui regalano un robot che parlava gli
portava da bere e lo trattava come
praticamente una badante in casa non
avete sempre sognato di averla una cosa
del genere Emilio è esattamente quello
Ma perché far parlare me quando possiamo
far parlare il suo spot il suo
famosissimo spot Sì tu sei nel posto
sveglio sai che è lì è proprio meglio se
tu sei un bimbo sveglio sai che è meglio
È proprio il meglio hanno fatto tre rime
in una strofa quali rapper e tra l'altro
ti spingevano a comprarlo perché ti
dicevano bimbo Sei un bambino sveglio e
che ti fai comprare gli altri giocattoli
e l'equivalente di uno schiavo
Emilio parla con la tua voce non
c'è un momento in cui lui fa
l'occhiolino e mi è sempre salito il
cuore in gola perché non credo che
nessuno dei bambini se ne sia accorto e
lui l'abbia fatto alla telecamera Questa
è come la scena di It Ve lo ricordate
quando c'è la fotografia che fa
l'occhiolino e poi esce tutto il sangue
dall'album fotografico Questa è a quel
livello lì eh oh abbiamo la prima
chiamata da casa Pronto Ciao sono Mirko
dalle marche Ciao Mirko dalle marche
Chiedimi tutto quello che vuoi dalla mia
televisione sembra che ti stai pelando
No non sono pelato e che se mi inclino
all'ingiù la luce passa attraverso i
capelli e quindi sembra che io ne abbia
meno ma in realtà è solo un trucco
cinematografico a me sembri proprio tua
madre Probabilmente chi l'ha comprato i
tempi lo saprà Ma chi non lo ha comprato
sapeva che all'interno di Emilio ci
fosse un certificato stellare non ho ben
capito ma sembrerebbe che ad ogni Emilio
corrispondesse una stella in regalo
proprio ti regalavano una stella con il
nome di Emilio e Ma quindi vuol dire che
nella Via Lattea c'è un'intera striscia
di stelle chiamate Emilio 1 2 3 qua ci
sei è meglio uno meglio due milioni non
lo so cioè voi non so neanche quanto sia
effettivamente vero questo certificato
perché su un certificato effettivo
stellare c'è il logo di Giochi Preziosi
quindi però bambini una cosa di miglio
si sapeva era fidanzato non lo sapevate
Ebbene sì nonostante fosse chiuso in
casa tua per tutta la sua vita è
riuscito ad avere una consorte Martina
cuoricina
[Musica]
Martina cammina e ti dà sempre una mano
parla con la tua voce anche tu sei
carina e se le fai un complimento
arrossisce come te no no Dice che se le
fai un complimento arrossisce e se le
fai un complimento arrossisce come te
avevano questa tecnologia negli anni 90
se tu potevi dire un complice potevi
dire qualsiasi cosa lei non avrebbe
detto nulla ma un complimento arrossiva
come la tecnologia degli anni 90 per un
giocattolo per bambini avrebbe potuto
fare una cosa del genere come avrebbe
potuto analizzare il sintetizzatore
vocale un complimento da un'altra roba
ma se era solo un microfono come ma come
adesso qualcuno che ce l'ha vogliono
sapere qualcuno che ce l'ha ma io non è
possibile questa cosa Che cos'è Io robot
che cos'è sta roba Martina fuoricina è
già che Preziosi Martina
[Musica]
di cuore
pistola ad acqua perché bambini vi sto
facendo vedere questa cosa qua Purtroppo
il mondo dei giocattoli non è come ve lo
immaginate voi c'è un Sottobosco piccole
ragadi di giocattoli economici per
famiglie che non hanno i soldi che hanno
le vostre o semplicemente hanno una zia
che vuole fare un regalo a un nipote ma
purtroppo non ha idea dei suoi gusti
della marca rana pistola ad acqua la
bocca si apre per schizzare questa
pistola ad acqua migliora le vostre
abilità sportive
per migliorare le vostre abilità nello
sport basta premere il cazzo che c'è di
questa rana ah ah
Ma io scherzavo ovviamente il mondo non
è fatto solo di questi giocattoli
bambini ci sono anche dei giocattoli
molto molto interessanti c'è qualcuno
che dice che i giocatori degli anni 90
fossero molto più creativi molto più
belli di quelli che ci sono adesso me lo
dovreste dire voi io questo non lo posso
sapere quello che so però è che molto
spesso vengono fatte delle versioni
moderne dei giochi degli anni 90 come
nel caso
di brivido come dicevo prima non è
l'unica riproposizione in chiave moderna
ce ne sono tante altre tra cui una che
poca gente conosce che è lì nella parte
più in basso degli scaffali che ti
guarda e ti giudica Perché sa di essere
soltanto una copia di quello che una
volta era un capolavoro che tutti
volevano in casa Non so perché ma questo
design è perfetto il sorriso gli occhi
le sirene della polizia qua sopra è le
braccia lungo i fianchi il fatto che non
fosse longilineo ma fosse tozzo sul
petto e le spalle È proprio figo è un
dettaglio che non avevo mai visto e la
maniglia c'è una maniglia in testa
Poverino e poi abbiamo il telecomando ho
già inserito le batterie sia sia sia
all'interno delle di questo l'antenna
molto vecchio stile Non ci resta che
accenderlo che dovrebbe essere qua
dietro
e sperare che funzioni Allora io accendo
questo che
non faccende però non c'è la luce quindi
io spero funzioni e accendiamo Emilio
provo
si sente ha fatto un suono una statica
della radio
che ha funzionato sto veramente usando
Emilio Devo aspettare Ci sono due avanti
e due indietro in questo controller e
uno lo manda avanti alla sinistra
L'altro manda avanti a destra e l'altro
indietro a sinistra indietro a destra
vedi se li premi entrambi va dritto vada
non gira da nessuna parte Vedi prova pro
Eccolo prova prova prova
funziona davvero allora via tutto
[Musica]
questa cosa che state vedendo è un sogno
che si avvera da anni e anni e anni e
anni
ma è terribile alle mani pensili e lui
aveva il suo vassoio che era questo tubo
col vassoio sopra purtroppo non ce
l'abbiamo Ma io voglio fare il test del
bicchiere d'acqua io voglio fare come
nella pubblicità che portava il
bicchiere d'acqua alle persone io voglio
farlo Datemi un bicchiere d'acqua Dov'è
Emilio qui con mamma torna mia come
vedete per i bambini Ci vuole un po' di
tempo per imparare ad utilizzarlo non è
per tutti questo va giocato con i propri
genitori Mi raccomando ci siamo Emilio
ci siamo fermo che prendo
Qui fermo così perfetto Eccolo qui il
bicchiere d'acqua
è caduta tutta attenzione
[Musica]
Grazie mille
vuoi andare Emilio Vai
rendi la vita di miliardi di bambini
migliore è il portafoglio dei genitori
più leggero
bambini le luci Emilio
[Musica]
Nord VPN Ve lo ricordate sì che nordvpn
di protegge quando vi connettete alle
reti pubbliche bravi ma non VPN è molto
più di una normale VPN se attivate il
Tret Protection potete proteggere il
vostro computer la vostra connessione
anche da malware per esempio o da pop up
molto invadenti e tra l'altro di Emilio
in Italia ne vendono un sacco usati ma
se siete all'estero magari non riuscite
e con nordvpn potete connettervi ad un
IP italiano per provare a trovarne uno
hai capito tutto Emilio
Dio mio Che incubo e se cercate in
descrizione c'è il codice sconto Yotobi
in cui potete usufruire delle promozioni